the conflict in ukraine could spiral and
spread in many ways and one focus is now
on a tiny breakaway state within moldova
a series of mysterious explosions in
transnistria hinted a possible troubling
new front
fears are growing that the territory is
about to play a crucial role in the
conflict between russia and ukraine
here's why
officially transnistria is part of
moldova a strip of land wedged between
the rest of the country to the west and
ukraine to the east
but in 1990 as the soviet union
collapsed it declared itself to be an
independent soviet republic
moldova left it as a de facto breakaway
state but it's still regarded
internationally as part of moldova
leaving the territory and its nearly 500
000 inhabitants in limbo
since then and this is why it's so
important the territory has retained
close ties to russia and is heavily
dependent on moscow's support
a towering statue of vladimir lenin
stands in the middle of the main square
in its capital city tiraspol
it's home to over a thousand russian
troops and its economy is reliant on
russian subsidies
we are not separate with
30 years live in peace with russian
soldiers
30 years ago we have war with moldavian
we not want
same to we want to peace with moldavian
with ukraine
we
we're not dangerous i have never
lived in a recognized country at least
well yes i have during the first seven
years of my life
but i don't remember
how it is so i'm perfectly fine with the
way that things are now
the concern is that russia is beginning
to create its own justification for
using transnistria to cut off the
southwestern corner of ukraine
but with moldova's long-term standoff
with the territory this invasion could
lead to russia intervening directly
inside the rest of moldova our you know
future
as an independent state does depend to a
great degree on how successful ukraine
is in fighting for its independence in
uh in resisting and ultimately surviving
as an independent state
moldova is constitutionally neutral it
has no functioning army and does not
have the protection of either the eu or
nato membership
on april the 25th cctv and terrazpol
transnistria's main city captured the
moment in broad daylight when three men
fired rocket-propelled grenades at the
state security office
no one was injured in the attack and the
men escaped
russia blames ukraine for the attacks
but ukraine insists that this is a
planned provocation by russia the
attacks happened days after a senior
russian general claimed that russian
speakers in moldova and transnistria
were being oppressed they are arguments
which echo those used by russia to
justify its invasion of ukraine
moldova has the large contingent of
russian speakers not only in
transnistria but in moldova proper and
they've been real sort of effort to
mobilize russian speakers in favor of
the war in ukraine so moldova is
something that russians would like to
see in ukraine the russian war and the
russian forces actually being welcomed
by the russian speakers and ethnic
russians in moldova and this may also be
something that they really would like to
see
this is not the end of the story ukraine
is the beginning
if russia succeeds in ukraine moldova
will be next on the menu
the kremlin took the surprising step of
publishing its intentions for this next
phase of its war and it specifically
mentions transnistria
according to the russian ministry of
defence its four main objectives in the
next phase are to take over the donbass
in ukraine's far east create a land
corridor from there to crimea blockade
ukraine's black sea ports like odessa
and then it says to control southern
ukraine creating an exit to transnistria
phase one of russia's war was a
comprehensive disaster and resulted in a
retreat from kiev and parts of northern
ukraine phase two is being conducted by
a regrouped and re-armed russian army
from the east and under a new command
they may now be in a better position to
achieve their goals
with this new threat that russia will
essentially bookend its assault from
east to west in ukraine comes an
increased unease for the rest of eastern
europe
if russia decides to play the
transnistria card it could change
everything